[ __ ] they say all lives matter you know
and um i believe that you know for the
most part
but then i think about
black lives matter you know and um to me
that's significant you know um
i remember being raised in the
neighborhood in our training ground
was you know the neighborhood and i
remember back then
i think my training started in the 80s
that's when they had the red and the
blue thing going on back then and
um you had to be real careful how you
navigated the streets back then
you know you had to be careful what
colors you wore in the neighborhoods you
were in and stuff like that because you
were caught in the wrong
area but the wrong color then you can
you can be a um what they call a
statistic
and i learned early on that it was no
joke indeed
trying to navigate in the concrete
jungle
of my neighborhood you know and then um
i got some more training later on down
the road and that was in the form of
being in prison
so while in prison i remember being on
those level threes and level four yards
but they had the gun towers
and he had the barbed wire and they had
the walls and i had to walk a fine thin
line just to get through that so what
was important for me
as far as the lessons i learned in
prison was
when you police yourself there's a good
chance that you want to have none of the
inmates hovering over
your ass um um talking to you and
checking yours
on one of your your mistakes or one of
your flukes
and another thing is you don't have the
cos in your bed area
causing trouble and all that kind of
stuff because back in the days
in prison if you had a problem with a co
it was a it was a good chance that he
knew some men up in there
and he would sick them on your ass and
they would deal with you accordingly
and i think they heard a lot of men
a lot of people got hurt under those by
bylaws
as they say and um i think they just
stopped doing that
recently now the last time i was in
prison i was gone from um
2011 to 2017 and i think in 2015
they stopped whipping on the men for the
cos in prisons man
and i think that came from from a level
like from the heads like
from the um from the from the head
people in charge man that's already in
prison at different ones man i think
they
rode a kite and shot that [ __ ] down the
line and it went from level to level one
from the level four
to i think it came all the way from
pelican bay from the big shots of new
york man that ran
[ __ ] that really runs stuff man behind
the scenes and so it came from the love
came from pelican bay to the level four
to the level threes tools ones and fire
camps and all that
and it said no more putting your hands
on each other for the public for the cos
for the correctional officers
and that didn't happen man and i was in
prison at the time when that took place
man what a relief
man so training oh man it's real
important man because if you don't get
it your ass is gonna get it
you know what i mean
when it comes to black lives matter
self-deception and self-hate that that
[ __ ] run it's a fine line man on how you
look at it man
because overall i remember when i was
growing up and i was caught up in that
self-deception
now if i heard about somebody around the
corner getting shotters
or the police shooting somebody down the
street across town i'll say oh man i
feel so bad
you know but it wouldn't it wouldn't
penetrate it it was like
i didn't i didn't feel the empathy i
couldn't put myself in in their shoes in
his mama's shoes or his
his his sibling shoes and nothing like
that i would just read about it or
hear about it on tv and i said oh man he
doesn't ain't that sad
you know he said um you know
little ray ray or or ronnie or a little
bobby
you know um bobo you know whoever
whoever it was at the time and um
sort of self-deception that [ __ ] was
with me from the early beginning man so
as long as it didn't happen the longer
nothing bad didn't happen to me or to
any of my family members then
i was going with the flow you know just
just rolling with the times man whatever
was going on at that time
in my life and then comes the second
half of that fine thin line when it
comes to really does it really matter
about black lives or any lives in
particular hail [ __ ] all for
the simple fact that
self-hatred i couldn't see past
if somebody got shot or somebody got ran
over hit and run or whatever the case it
may be with that self-hatred thing man
it was like man i don't give a [ __ ] i
really don't
i don't care it doesn't matter because
it didn't i didn't notice i didn't know
the joke
or the mary or whoever it was that might
got injured at the time
and that's how deep that [ __ ] was i said
on tv and i look at it i read about it
in the newspaper or in the book
somewhere like that
and it wouldn't even register man it
wouldn't register
and that's real no empathy no sympathy
no nothing
because i didn't care how can i care
about somebody else man when i don't
care about my damn self
when push come to shove instead of
self-deception and that self-hatred man
that [ __ ] that's a fine thin line when
it comes to any lives matter man because
when it's all said and done you don't
give a [ __ ] about nobody
nothing to nobody because your actions
my actions showed me that
i didn't care i didn't care about me i
didn't give a [ __ ] what happened to me
i didn't care if i got shot robbed and
stabbed and all that kind of stuff
man it didn't matter
it took a long time for it to matter
took a long time for my life to matter
for me to matter
to me
going through the motions and all that
[ __ ]
every time i interact with somebody how
you doing all man everything's good
yeah [ __ ] everything wasn't good
but i couldn't admit it i couldn't tell
you that
oh did you hear about so-and-so did you
hear about so-and-so
yeah i heard about whoop the woo okay
and
move on to the next phase what's the
next thing on agenda on elino
you know and that that's the way that's
that's that's just the way it was man
for a long time
nothing registered nothing penetrated me
man nothing got me to see the other
person's man or
other family situation or circumstances
and all that kind of stuff
and um but i had to i had the right kind
of training i had the proper training
you know because i had three different
types of trainings you know i had the
neighborhood training
i had the prison setting setting praying
uh training
and then after that i had my own
personal training from from from taking
a look at
the the the neighborhood training the
prison training
and implementing them into one and then
taking them on
and looking at them and making them work
for me so i had to mold them and scooped
them
into something that fit me that it may
have me being
having me being able to navigate on
these streets as a free man
and um so being on the streets
i'll police myself in order to do that
in order to make sure i stay out of
trouble i know i mean uh make sure not
to stay out of harm's way man i don't
put myself in that position
and speaking truthfully to you all
[ __ ] aside
i've did 19 trips to prison and in that
time i had to i had to
had to deal with the police on those 19
different occasions
they never beat me up they never hurt me
they never did no racial slurs i never
been
shot so when it really comes to to me
identifying with somebody that's
probably gotten beaten up
or or been recently slurred or whatever
comes with the territory we're dealing
with some of those bad seeds
my bad bad apples then i can sympathize
but i can't empathize because nothing
bad has never happened to me in those 19
on those 19 times that i have to
interact with those dudes man
you know or should i say for them coming
to my rescue
you know in in in in a in a in a real
way
you know because sometimes man i just
begging pray for them to come
and rescue me man for me and the
[ __ ] that i was dealing with man
within myself or some [ __ ] that i hadn't
created that i couldn't handle
and i had to go i had to get up out of
there exit stage left people
now you see me now you don't i wasn't
bullshitting when i get too hot in the
kitchen i know where to go i know how to
skate
but for the life of me i never thought
that my interactions with the police
would
will cause me any harm you know i never
i never imagined ever fathom that
you know even when all this stuff is
going on around me while i'm hearing
about this happening
and that taking place in this state and
over here you know like i said their
self-deception that [ __ ] just had me
like oh well [ __ ] it ain't me
it ain't nobody in my family so i can
live with that and i could a long time
long as it didn't hit home
during those 19
times i had to to see them you know
always looked at their mess okay you
guys
are here to protect and serve their
community to which i live in
you know and um you guys are civil
servants so that means you're you're at
my bet and call
you know so when it comes to interacting
and dealing with me i'm supposed to feel
comfortable i'm supposed to feel this or
that kind of certain way when you're
around
but even as a youngster as a teenager i
remember being young
and have been just with my friends man
we're playing in the streets we're
playing tag we're playing football
and they passed by and i got this messed
up feeling in my spirit man in my
soul man on my stomach i got this funny
feeling
and it wasn't a good feeling and i said
i wonder where that's where that comes
from
because i never had any negative
dealings with the police
but every time i would see them man i
would get this funny feeling in my
in my soul man and i remember
they would come by and we'll be hanging
out on the block as teenagers man they
jump out the car and want to be nosy and
ask questions and all that [ __ ]
and my palms are starting to get sweaty
then i feel it's
this uncomfortable feeling you know i'm
like damn where is this coming from
and i had no idea man that that was that
was just
that was part of the the real me
not the self-deception not the
self-hatred but that real
feeling that was going on within me even
though nothing bad ever happened it was
that identification
to all the other people that that
[ __ ] then happened too that's what
that feeling was
let me know warning warning warning it
could be your ass
you know so it's time to be on the top
of your game it's time to be
you got to come with your a game with
them you know
because because you could be next you
know i could be next
and um [ __ ] man that's more so true now
than at any point in place and time in
my
life i'm 53 years old man and i've it's
been
more it's a bit more
magnified man as as as um i get past
these little personal
things these little personal like
character traits or these these personal
um
um how can i say i want to overcome a a
a personal a character defect you know a
personal flaw with the
with the self-deception and the
self-hatred once i make it to the other
side my eyes open and something new was
revealed to me
and what's been revealed to me is man
i'm not exempt
from something bad happening to me by
the hands of the police
you know i'm not special i'm not unique
and i better not let my guards down for
one second
i better keep on with my a game so every
time i see them if my [ __ ]
palms get sweaty then let them get
sweaty
don't stop getting sweaty don't let me
stop getting that nervousness don't let
me stop feeling that feeling deep in the
pit of my [ __ ]
my stomach that needs to be there i need
to stay there because that keeps me
aware of
what's really going on because the
blinders is off
[ __ ] i got to see it for what it is that
could be me
i could man i'm george
i'm emma tiermann malcolm x
dr martin luther king jr
[ __ ] i'm that [ __ ] that played
in rosewood the boy on swole
veen rhymes right now that's me all i
have to do is put myself in the shoes
and it's easy today it's not horry
because when i look in the mirror guys
who's looking back at me each and every
one of them
from rosa parks
harriet tubman
net turner
they live within me they live within my
spirit they guide me
they pray for me they work with me they
abide in me
because if i wouldn't even know that
[ __ ] unless i read up on it i had to
read the books and see the movies to get
that
to get that part of me
[ __ ] i'm a part of them every last one
of them because i'm
free i'm not slave to a [ __ ]
thing the only way i can be in bondage
is the [ __ ] that i put to myself
that's the only way i'll ever be a slave
to anything it's some [ __ ] that i create
that's the only way i'll be a [ __ ] i
got to do it to myself
[ __ ] the police can't even do to me what
i did to myself over the years
dealing with that drinking and them
drugs [ __ ] me up
and i'll forever be scored need to write
a book about that but all boys should
aside
it does matter black lives matter all
lives are mighty because today my life
matters
my life means something to me the cold
thing about it
is back when i was growing in
back when i was growing up in the
neighborhood when somebody got shot or
somebody got stabbed or whatever the
reason somebody came through
the police came through and shot up the
house and did this i blew up some [ __ ]
it wasn't a marching over there in the
name of the person or the name of the
house or whoever it was at that time
and that hasn't changed now you got a
lot you got a lot of people talking
about the black on black crime the black
on black this the black on black that
that's true
but you got that in every race but don't
eat the only things they show
don't eat the only things they show on
tv is the black on blacks
the atrocities that we commit against
ourselves man
you know but it's one thing that bothers
me about that
i remember uh when i first came home
from prison
i was going from 2011 to 2017 and i went
to my mom's house man
and i remember walking down the street
and there are some railroad tracks man
but that was a shortcut to get to the
train to the green line
and um instead of walking to the corner
and going up to
to um vermont and just walking to the
train
i take the shortcut down the side street
go go go uh pass the uh the railroad
tracks
until i get to the green line and i
remember seeing some candles
a makeshift cross and some flowers and
all that [ __ ]
and i'm like damn uh i wondering what
happened so i'll get back to the house
and she run it down to me oh um
yesterday's uh somebody came through and
killed so-and-so down on it
yeah i saw the little makeshift uh yeah
that's what happened there
and it was like maybe once every other
week man i would see a makeshift candle
man a makeshift with the counters and
all that [ __ ]
on the side of the different parts of
the railroad tracks man
you know and um either the police then
did it or it was just somebody just
happened to get caught up at the wrong
place at the wrong time but i don't see
nobody marching
for them
now if i was caught up in that
[ __ ] self-deception it wouldn't
even dawned on me
where they at who was that person who
was that boy who was that girl who was
that woman who was that man
because i'm walking the same
[ __ ] trail i'm walking the same
path i mean i'm walking the same route
so i know i'm not exempt from somebody
roll up on me pushing up on me
i go the same way and it's dangerous
mom used to tell me man go the long way
hell no i'm not going the long way
because it's the long way i take my
chances on the danger of the shortcut
you know it's just the way i'm wired man
ain't that some [ __ ]
cause i don't want to walk the long way
around
i rather take my chances on getting shot
or some [ __ ] like that
that's the way to gesture where the
chips flow uh fall man let them fall
where they lay
[ __ ] and um
so the blindness is outfit that's
self-deception so i wonder when i'd be
walking by those makeshift crosses and
the candles in a little teddy bear
who was that child who was that son who
was that brother who was that sister
who was that man who was that woman
i know there ain't no family i know
we're not related but god damn
where they had where the marchers had
where to pick up where the picket signs
and all that [ __ ] the crowds and all
that
what a microphone is that where's al
sharpton and all that [ __ ] single
cool by y'all
he's at the george floyd's and all that
boys [ __ ] with his with his hell of a
hell of a uh uh uh uh uh speech right
ness
you know uh l sharpton he gave a hell of
a little testimony man
at georgia's services man but i never
seen that [ __ ] in the
neighborhood
i ain't never seen him over there by the
railroad tracks man
and since i've been man i was with my
mom a year and a half man and i hadn't
seen
seven different makeshift crosses and
candles man doing a year and a half
that's seven lives in a year and a half
man that i got to pay
tribute to that i got to pay witness to
every time i walk to the train i have to
pass by
take a pause for the calls and look at
it and see the picture of whoever that
individual was
they're going about my business thank
you god thank god it ain't me
but i had time man to take that pause
for the calls and that's what made the
difference
that's what penetrated my my insensitive
ass
you know me not wanting to know me not
giving a [ __ ] me not caring
you know that was enough
so now when they talk about black lives
matter um
for for the last one whatever the last
thing that went on over here
with the brother george um george bluff
or whatever his name is man i didn't
march
hell no i didn't feel like it
you know but i appreciate all the people
that did
i wanted to so bad but at the times
where i was going to do it
it was just too much going on at the
time man so i didn't i i couldn't
but i wanted to and the cool thing about
it is man i had that empathy
so i put myself in those protesters
shoes i put myself in
in in in his his people's shoes his
family member shoes
now i shot i saw the the sir
i saw the um the tribute they gave him
with the ceremony and all that kind of
stuff and it was beautiful man i love
the brothers and sisters that showed up
i love the singers i love everybody that
contributed and all that kind of stuff
but i need to see them with the with the
average [ __ ] joes
i need to see those with the nameless
ones in the neighborhood man
i need to see them sing and dance and
shouting and all that other [ __ ] too
man because there's too many of us dying
man
and i don't see enough [ __ ] in
the neighborhood marching i don't see
them picking
and all that [ __ ] i don't see what
they makeshift stands and all that kind
of [ __ ] got the music going got the
choir and all that other stuff
no you just see a makeshift
[ __ ] cross with the candles man
in the picture this person
that's it that's all the recognition you
get then when kobe bryant died
you got the whole world in the
[ __ ] upper everybody's doing
something for kobe
and i don't take nothing away from kobe
i love kobe i was in the deep depression
for three days
behind his ass and his daughter getting
uh uh dying
she killed me hurt me to the core
the whole world was affected by that
then you had this girl of mine in my
building complex she tripped down the
stairs and broke her [ __ ] neck
all he had was a little picture of her
no makeshift no shrine no nothing just a
picture and a couple roses
and let me tell you the coldest thing
about that situation
she had broke her neck walking down the
stairs
two days prior to kobe bryant and his
daughter getting killed in that
helicopter uh crash
you know what kobe bryant took
precedence over her little thing that
happened in my building
and let me share something that's cold
that i never witnessed in my
[ __ ] life
as i'm coming out my apartment going
down the stairs
i see her family coming down getting
ready to exit the building
you got the mama you got the sister you
got the brother and you got a little
brother
and they're all carrying plastic trash
bags
i guess that was all her possessions and
trash bags
and i knew it was her family by the look
in their faces
i know it was i looked at the mama's how
to look at her mother
in her first life she couldn't believe
it like damn my baby
i didn't see nobody i didn't see no
orchestra there
i just see no greeting committee like
they do at [ __ ] walmart and
target
have somebody greet your ass when you
walk in the store
on the senior welcoming committee i seen
her tired
broken down family leaving with all her
stuff in
trash bags all her rolling possessions
god damn i wonder what it was like when
they was going through her little
apartment
getting all her or her personal effects
man
oh i wouldn't want to be in them shoes
man but i had to place myself in on
shoes i had to be there
so thank god i got to see that because
doing the whole thing with kobe bryant
and his daughter
i got the witness i got to see that i
got to see that
part her i got to see who loved her
who cared enough about her
that's a theme
that meant more to me than the kobe
thing man
because somebody showed up for her
and they didn't bring no band
they didn't bring no special speeches
and no no [ __ ] got to do the
talking for none of that
they didn't need no intermediates no
translations
none of that stuff they didn't come with
the marching band
they didn't come with it with the
harmony singers they came
quietly and got her stuff and left the
same way they
came invisible i was so shook up i
didn't even pay homage man i couldn't
even say nothing it's bad i want to say
something my condolences to the mom and
all of them
it shook me up so bad just seeing them
in that procession leaving
it just i just oh my god it just it
floored me
and i got i'm just watching in slow
motion
as they're walking off somewhere solely
with her personal stuffs men in trash
bags
and he exited the building and i said
i'll never see them again
and i'll never see her again and i'd
even deal with her on the regular basis
to see her in passing but a beautiful
kinder spirit
beautiful woman
[Music]
so that's what i'll do so that was the
point that was a turning point for me
when it happened in my building with
that woman
so until i see people
protesting and marching for the ones man
that's not famous that's
not rich man that that didn't die by the
hands of the police
if you can't march for them then while
you're marching for the ones that's
gonna bring you some exposure man
because it's a lot of us dying man right
left that don't have that kind of
exposure man
but we need it you know there's a lot of
mamas there's a lot of daddies there's a
lot of grandmas in the neighborhood man
scared to death you know i just came
from visiting my mother just yesterday
man
and and and every time she talk about
man i walk around the corner i walk down
the street you know i'll be like god
watch over this one man
she's all i got you know watch over this
one please
i would hate to see something bad happen
to her man on a hamburg man on the fluke
man happenstance
you know that [ __ ] it just it it it'd do
something to me
you know because i love my mama you know
my mama's boy
you know but she get up and she get
around me like she's supposed to and i
ain't mad at her
you know but that's a dangerous ass
street and that's a dangerous size
corner about where the railroad tracks
are man
it ain't changed she don't even go that
way i still do
and i ain't that some [ __ ] i'm not
playing with fire i'm not playing with
the game
[ __ ] that's my choice you know i'm long
i've been making bad choices decisions
in my life on almost every [ __ ]
thing that i've experienced in my life
too many so i'm learning how to make the
right choices and decisions today
i'm not perfect [ __ ] i got a long way to
go in certain areas
but i'm not going to give up the good
fight for what's right
and um i'm leaning more towards doing a
protest for any injustice man no matter
who it is because it ain't about just
black lives matter which is important
man but it's like all lives matter
but some people just don't see the
importance of the black life
man some people just don't get it that
that black men and
black women man we're important man
we're worthy man we're somebody where
we're something special man
if not to your [ __ ] ass if
somebody love us enough somebody care
enough about us you ain't never met them
you probably never will see them so
whoever got them civil servant jobs as
the police and the shirts and all that
[ __ ]
who don't have that temperament maybe
you need to check your [ __ ]
training
and if it's the technique if you saw one
of your one of your partners or
uh another officer have somebody need a
chokehold or had their foot on your neck
and you saw somebody die
now you wouldn't know going and going
into the next person that you might come
across that you wouldn't try that [ __ ]
cuz you know it don't work
so if you're still trying some [ __ ] that
you saw somebody will choose that kill
somebody
then [ __ ] you you know you're wrong
because you know you you know what it
did
i'm an ex cracks i'm an ex crack smoker
i if so if i'm walking down the street i
was a [ __ ] crack house man and
i know they have been there willing and
dealing and smoking their [ __ ]
asses off
i'm not going to go up in there because
i know what i got coming
i know how bad i got i know how bad i am
so that would tip my ass i don't give a
[ __ ] if you got the pie piper leaving a
thousand people in and out there all day
i'm not gonna jump in line with them
because i already know what i got coming
already know better
because i know it's nothing good it's
all bad
so to all the police officers up man if
you're not a civil servant if you're not
up for the job then please man find
something else to do
and if you got man let me share some
with you man even during my training
days in the neighborhood man it was
always too absolute for me man and it
was a
a racist a racist society man
in a system that was set up man
especially when i got to the to the
criminal justice system i got to see how
the system was set up man because
a lot of people that go in and out of
the the criminal justice systems are
people of color
black men a lot of black men i saw in
you know because all of my 19 trips to
prison and all those holding cells
all those holding tanks the majority is
black i'm like 85 percent black
got a few uh hispanics and you got a few
whites sprinkled in just to add the
flavor to it
you know and um i saw the majority of us
we didn't have attorneys personal
attorneys we couldn't afford
private attorneys to represent us so we
had to get the public defenders
and they didn't give a [ __ ] i didn't
find out this until the 15th trip to
prison
that they really didn't care we're just
a number man
you know what you what you got they
making deals with the d.a hey man i'm
gonna give you these three right here
man i'll let this [ __ ] right
here go he got a petty theft man this is
20th time we'll let him go he's just he
just can't get it right but he rolls
sooner or later
and he that's how he's doing his
bartering trading and we're human beings
you know we're human beings
so now at 53 years old i'm more mindful
i'll police myself more and i'm more
that scared
man when i run across the police even
though nothing's bad never happened to
me
god damn when i'm not exempt that's why
it is i'm more scared than ever i'm more
fearful now
because i don't want to be the next
george bro i don't want to be the next
one
george floyd emma tillman
malcolm x man i don't give a [ __ ] who it
is it ain't even got to be no
i just don't want to be the next one i
don't want to be the next statistic
because i can't be and it's real easy
so i bring my a game and if i don't have
my a game on
during the beginning of the day i keep
my ass at home i don't even go nowhere
if i'm not if i'm not gonna represent to
the top of my game because i don't need
to be out there
[ __ ] shucking and jiving
in a [ __ ] way because as soon
as i get my ass in a way that's when all
hill breaks loose man and it's always
been like that and always will
so i'm not out here on the streets just
to be out here just to find something to
get into if anything
if anything to get into i don't get into
nothing if there's nothing to do i don't
do nothing i stay put
i don't need i'm not looking for trouble
today because it's too easy to find and
it's hard as hell to get out of
it's not easy does all lives matter
yes they do absolutely no doubt but most
importantly man for those who don't
believe who don't think so black lives
matter too it starts with me and it ends
with me
but i'ma say it like this it starts it
starts with us
and it ends with the soul now during the
time where i had that self-hatred i
didn't give a [ __ ] about no black life
matter cuz i couldn't stand my black ass
it took me a long time to to come to the
other side of that that's that [ __ ]
right there with the self-hatred
you know by my upbringing and all the
[ __ ] that i went on in my life and
all my experiences leading up to me
being a teenager
leading up to being a young adult into
manhood by the time i got to manhood man
i was so disgusted with me
and in my race and all that [ __ ] men
and i hated being black man because i
was poor
and i was black and i was in real
trouble at an early age man and i saw
the [ __ ] writings on the wall
man around seven or eight years old
i saw what i was destined for i wasn't
bullshitting when i say that i mean that
from the bottom of my [ __ ]
heart
i knew where i was headed and it wasn't
nothing that could stop me from getting
there and i got there on the fast track
if i didn't get past that self-deception
and that self-hatred then black lives
wouldn't matter i wouldn't be up here
talking right now because it wouldn't
mean a [ __ ] thing to me
but since i got past it and to the other
side it means the world to me
because i'm speaking for myself too as a
black man living in los angeles
california
[ __ ] i can i got to represent me i got
to stand up for me i always say that
i'm all i got i got to be there for me
and take care of me you [ __ ]
right i got to take care of me that's
why i'm up here talking for me
because it matters today man i matter
i mean the real to me today and
and somebody somebody thinks the world
to me you know i got a mama that loved
me i got a sister i got siblings man i
got nieces i got nephews man they love
the uncle eric
now the average joe might say oh man
[ __ ] this dude man i ain't tripping on
him
and that's cool man that's your
prerogative it's your thing do what you
want to do i can't tell you who to sock
it to
but i know for me it's important man
that i reciprocate
to those who got that love for being as
genuine that's what keep me going that's
what keep me on
on my ding you know that's to kick me
out my dean
you know and um
so who's ever got that feeling like it
doesn't matter
they don't care they ain't happening
they hit close to home
that's all right man but you always got
to remember man try to put yourself in
somebody else's shoes man because you
can't and when it happened to you man
ain't nobody show for your [ __ ]
services or nobody show up to speak
anything good for you then you're gonna
know why
i got a partner um
that just passed man in an accident man
and
it was hard for his family man to you
know to kind of get everything situated
man had a real struggle man with the
finances for the brewery and all that
kind of stuff he needed some help man
and and went on on the social media man
to get some assistance man
and i was thinking about that you know
so what i learned from that experience
with my what my partner is
if i don't put nothing out there then i
can't get another return
so if i'm not doing anything if i'm not
shooting up and showing up
if i know if they're protesting for
injustices if i'm not out there trying
to do my part
then if something happened to me and
somebody in my family i can't expect
nobody to suit up and show up i can't
expect nobody to do make no donations
and all that kind of stuff
i can't i can't i can't expect that
because i didn't do it you know
what comes around goes around man i
believe that wholeheartedly man
so it's about time i got my black ass in
line and do what the [ __ ] i'm supposed
to do and that stand up
like everybody else is standing up for
any injustice man anywhere anytime that
goes on
[ __ ] they probably don't even feel like
it but they doing it
it was more other races this time for
george brown than any of anybody i've
seen
excuse me george floyd from anybody i've
seen in los angeles california downtown
olay
i'm being at the bus stop doing a
protest man and it was all these young
kids walking up and back
up down the street with their signs and
all that kind of stuff we're retired
and i'm like oh my god i'm like thank
you god for them
because i can't do it because i was
tired too
and i just didn't feel like to be honest
with you because i had so much other
stuff going on at the time but they took
the time out to do it
and that's my only regret i had time all
i had to do was make it
so some [ __ ] ever happened to me bad
then i hope nobody don't say that in my
behalf
oh i feel for uh young eric man for pool
e big e uncle e whatever the [ __ ]
yeah man i just ain't got the time man
something real important came up man i
just came
i can't be there for the brother like i
want to that'll hurt my family
especially for the few friends that i
have
and if they said some [ __ ] like that i'd
roll over my mouth and grave and try to
get the ass
so i have to be mindful what i put out
there
and i have to do my part and it's real
important man that actions speak louder
than words
so while i'm sitting up here give me
this [ __ ] i was gonna say song
and dance but it's not that
i'm gonna give you my testimony on being
a black man in los angeles and it is
important that actions follow these
words that i'm spitting man
i could have kept my ass at home and
have somebody else sit up here and tell
you this
or share this information with you or
this story
but black lives matter please don't get
it twisted thank you
you